BUT FIRST, A TEACHABLE MOMENT.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE."
A LITTLE PAST 24 HOURS, WE HAVE
GOTTEN A HUGE REACTION FOR LAST
NIGHT’S ANGLE ABOUT THE HORRIFIC
MURDER OF 6-YEAR-OLD BERNELL
TRAMMELL IN MILWAUKEE,
WISCONSIN.
HE WAS GUNNED DOWN IN BROAD DAY
LIGHT ONE WEEK AGO, MR. TRAMMELL
HAD BEEN A FIXTURE IN THE RIVER
WEST NEIGHBORHOOD AND A
SUPPORTER OF BOTH BLM AND LATELY
THE REELECTION OF
DONALD J. TRUMP.
DESPITE THE POET HOLDING A REAL
TRUMP SIGN WAS UNUSUAL TO SAY
THE LEAST.
SOME BELIEVE HIS KILLING WAS
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED.
WHILE THE POLICE ARE STILL
INVESTIGATING, BASED ON DEMAND
SHOWN IN THIS PHOTO, AND THEY
SAY HE IS A PRIME LETTER COMIC
MURDER SUSPECT.
AS OF THIS EVENING NEITHER BLM
NOR SINGLE DEMOCRAT ELECTED
OFFICIAL IN THE STATE OF
WISCONSIN HAS COMMENTED ON
MR. TRAMMELL’S DEATH.
NOT A PEEP FROM MILWAUKEE
MAYOR TOM BARRETT.
NOTHING FROM WISCONSIN
GOVERNOR TONY EVERT.
NOTHING FROM ATTORNEY GENERAL
JOSH CALL.
NOT ANY OF THE DEMOCRAT
CONGRESSMAN, NONE HAVE EXPRESSED
THEIR CONDOLENCES OR OUTRAGE
ABOUT THE POSSIBLE POLITICAL
SLAYING OF A PEACEFUL
LAW-ABIDING AFRICAN-AMERICAN MAN
MAN.
THE EARSPLITTING SILENCE WITH A
DISTURBING PATTERN OF DEMOCRAT
DISINTEREST IN THE LARGER
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY AS
WELL.
SINCE THE CORONAVIRUS LOCKDOWN
AND RACIAL JUSTICE PROTEST
BEGAN, KILLINGS OF BLACK MEN,
WOMEN AND EVEN CHILDREN HAVE
SKYROCKETED.
BUT NOT AT THE HANDS OF BAD
COPS.
OVERWHELMINGLY THESE MURDERS
HAVE BEEN COMMITTED BY OTHER
AFRICAN-AMERICAN MEN.
NOW, OF COURSE, AL SHARPTON AND
BLM ACTIVIST DON’T SHOW UP TO
MARCH AGAINST THIS CARNAGE.
NO CALL FOR THE REMOVAL OF
MAYORS AND GOVERNORS WHO REFUSED
TO TACKLE VIOLENT CRIME AND DO
SO HEAD ON.
NO CELEBRITIES DOING INSTAGRAM
LIVE CONCERTS IN MEMORY OF THE
VICTIM.
WHY IS THAT?
BECAUSE THERE IS NO POLITICAL
BENEFIT IN IT, THAT IS WHY.
NOW A SIMILAR SCENARIO IS
PLAYING OUT IN THE DEBATE OVER
REOPENING SCHOOLS IS FULL.
TEACHERS UNION JOINT AT THE HIP
WITH DEMOCRATS REFUSED TO RETURN
TO THEIR JOB.
TODAY IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
JOINED A SLEW OF OTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND ANNOUNCING THERE
WOULD BE ZERO IN PERSON LEARNING
FOR KIDS.
IT IS ALL GOING TO BE ONLINE.
PRETTY MUCH EVERY PEDIATRIC THAT
I HAVE SEEN BELIEVES THIS 100%
DISTANCE LEARNING APPROACH IS A
TOTAL DISASTER.
IT IS TERRIBLE FOR ALL CHILDREN
AND ALL PARENTS, BUT ESPECIALLY
FOR AT RISK KIDS FROM
SINGLE-PARENT FAMILIES.
>> WE KNOW THAT CHILDREN FROM
LOW INCOME FAMILIES IN
PARTICULAR WHO ARE BEING
HOMESCHOOLED, THEY ARE NOT
GETTING AN ADEQUATE EDUCATION
BECAUSE THEIR PARENTS ARE
WORKING.
>> PARTICULARLY THE YOUNGER
GROUP K THROUGH EIGHTH JUST DOES
NOT WORK.
>> THE LOWER INCOME FAMILIES,
THE CHILDREN TO NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO THE INTERNET.
THEY DON’T HAVE SUPPORT FOR
REMOTE LEARNING.
>> Laura: THAT HOW CAN
DEMOCRATS ENDORSE KEEPING KIDS
AT HOME FULL-TIME WHEN THE VIRUS
POSES A MINUSCULE THREAT TO
YOUNG AMERICANS?
AFTER ALL, DAY CARE CENTERS AND
ESSENTIAL WORKERS NEVER SHUT
DOWN AND GROCERY STORE
EMPLOYEES, THEY SHOW UP EVERY
DAY TO WORK AS DO BUS DRIVERS
AND NURSES.
SO WHY DO EDUCATORS GET A
SPECIAL STAY-AT-HOME PASS?
ESPECIALLY WHILE THEY CLAIM TO
CARE SO MUCH ABOUT THE WELFARE
OF THE CHILDREN.
>> THE ADMINISTRATION ARE
MESSING WITH THE HEALTH OF OUR
CHILDREN.
>> MOMS AND DADS ARE WORRIED.
I’M WORRIED THAT THE GRANDPARENT
WHETHER OUR GRANDKIDS WILL BE
ABLE TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL
SAFELY.
>> YOU KNOW, AS I SAID BEFORE,
THESE ARE NOT SOMEBODY ELSE’S
KIDS.
THEY ARE ALL OUR KIDS.
>> Laura: NO OF COURSE
SHUTTING DOWN IS THE ONLY ANSWER
FOR THE CORONAVIRUS.
FROM CALIFORNIA TO MICHIGAN, YOU
SEE A PRE-ELECTION MOMENTUM
BEGINNING TO BUILD TO EITHER
PAUSE OR REVERSE REOPENING.
TODAY, MARYLAND’S LIBERAL
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR LARRY HOGAN
CITED CASES IN OTHER STATES TO
JUSTIFY HIS OWN STATES
REOPENING.
>> WE WILL REMAINED PAUSED AT
THIS POINT AND NOT MOVE INTO
STAGE 3 OPENINGS UNTIL IT IS
SAFE, PRUDENT AND THOROUGHLY
BACKED BY THE DATA.
LOOK AT THESE OTHER STATES.
THEY HAVE BEEN DOING PRETTY WELL
AND SHUT UP AND WE DON’T WANT TO
BE ONE OF THEM.
>> Laura: IT IS UNBELIEVABLE
MONTGOMERY COUNTY, MARYLAND THE
NUMBERS ARE ACTUALLY REALLY
ENCOURAGING.
OF COURSE, THESE DECISIONS ARE
DRIVEN NOT BY WHAT IS GOOD FOR
THE GENERAL WELFARE BUT BY
POLITICS.
LOCKDOWNS PLUS TRILLIONS IN
WELFARE SPENDING AND TAUPE
APPARENTLY TO ZERO VIRUS IN
AMERICA.
THAT IS REALISTIC.
REMEMBER THE JUSTIFICATION FOR
STAY-AT-HOME ORDERS WAS THE NEED
TO PRESERVE THE HOSPITAL SYSTEM.
I CAN KIND OF UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT NOW THEY ARE USING THESE
LOCKDOWNS WERE PAUSES TO RESERVE
BIDEN’S CHANCES TO BEAT TRUMP.
IT IS TRULY DISGUSTING.
AND WHOM DO THESE LOCKDOWNS AND
SCHOOL CLOSURES END UP HURTING
THE MOST?
WELL RICK’S RICH FAMILIES HIRE
TUTORS AND TAKE UP NEW HOBBIES
AT HOME.
IT IS THE POOR FAMILIES THAT
WILL STRUGGLE TO HOLD DOWN JOBS
AND OVERSEE KIDS ZOOM CLASSES
AND ALL THE HOMEWORK.
THE DIVIDE BETWEEN THE HAVES AND
THE HAVE-NOTS WILL ONLY WIDEN.
BUT ONE GETS THE SENSE THE VIRUS
FEARMONGERING IS BEGINNING TO
WEAR THIN.
MORE FAMILY SEE THE NEED TO MOVE
ON TO PRESERVE WHAT WE HAVE
WHILE STILL PROTECTING THE MOST
VULNERABLE.
EVEN "THE NEW YORK TIMES" SEEMS
TO THINK THE UNIONS HAVE MAYBE
OVERSTEPPED AND RISK ALIENATING
MILLIONS OF VOTERS REPORTING
THAT TEACHERS IN MANY DISTRICTS
ARE FIGHTING FOR LONGER SCHOOL
CLOSURES MUST STRONGER SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS, AND LIMITS ON WHAT
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO DO WHEN
VIRTUAL CLASSROOMS.
WHILE FLOODING SOCIAL MEDIA AND
STATE CAPITALS WITH THEIR
CONCERNS AND THREATENING TO WALK
OFF OF THEIR JOBS IF THEY ARE
KEY DEMANDS ARE NOT MET.
DEMANDS?
NOW, THEY CAN SIT AT HOME AND
THEIR T-SHIRT AND SHORTS AND GET
THE SAME PAY AND THEY ARE
ISSUING DEMANDS?
THE MIAMI TEACHERS UNION IS
PUSHING TO LIMIT ONLINE
LEARNING, LIMIT ONLINE LEARNING.
YEAH, WHY?
ACCORDING TO THE TIMES, THEY
CITED ANXIETY ABOUT HOW THEY
AND THEIR HOMES WOULD LOOK ON
CAMERA DURING WIDE TEACHING.
SO THEY WON’T GO TO THE
CLASSROOM, AND THEY DON’T WANT
TO TEACH ONLINE.
THAT’S PERFECT.
WITH THE LOCAL UNION LEADER SAY
IF THE TEACHER DOES NOT FEEL
COMFORTABLE AND THE TEACHER IS
NOT COMFORTABLE IN THE MODALITY,
THEY WILL NOT FLOURISH AND GIVE
THE BEST OF THEMSELVES.
MODALITY?
WHAT ABOUT THE COMFORT OF
STUDENTS?
WILL THEY BE ABLE TO FLOURISH
COOPED UP IN THEIR HOME SHARING
A COMPUTER SCREEN WITH A BROTHER
OR SISTER OR IF THEY EVEN HAVE
ONE AND DO THIS FOR END?
THE LEFT DOESN’T CARE!
IF IT WAS REALLY ABOUT SAFETY,
WHY ARE TEACHERS UNION FIGHTING
REOPENING PLANS, EVEN IN STATES
WHERE THE VIRUS IS UNDER CONTROL
CONTROL.
AND WHY, FOR EXAMPLE, ONE OF THE
LOWEST COVID RATES IN THE
COUNTRY, TEACHERS ARE RESISTING
FULLY REOPENING, INCLUDING ON
THE SMALL ISLAND OF LANAI, WHICH
HAS ZERO, ZERO CONFIRMED CASES.
NOW, THANKFULLY PRESIDENT TRUMP
WANTS THE KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL.
HE HAS A SOLUTION FOR UNIONS AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT DO NOT PUT
KIDS FIRST.
>> IF THE SCHOOL DOESN’T WANT TO
REOPEN OR THE GOVERNOR DOESN’T
WANT TO OPEN MAY BE FOR
POLITICAL REASONS I MAY BE BUT
THERE IS SOME OF THAT GOING
ON.
THE MONEY SHOULD GO TO THE
PARENTS SO THAT THEY CAN SEND
THEIR CHILDREN TO THE SCHOOL OF
THEIR CHOICE.
>> Laura: BINGO!
SCHOOL CHOICE.
GO TO A SCHOOL THAT IS ACTUALLY
TEACHING.
THE NEA AND A FT ARE POWERFUL
FORCES, BUT IF THEY ONLY REMAIN
SO, I THINK IF AMERICANS
CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT PUBLIC
EDUCATION IS STILL WORTHWHILE,
BY REFUSING TO TEACH, BY
POLITICIZING CURRICULA, BY
JEOPARDIZING THE CHILDREN’S
MENTAL AND PHYSICAL WELL-BEING,